I feel really good about not feeling
muzzled anymore and it was my own doing
Taylor Swift celebrates not feeling
muzzled and shares a few sweet moments
with her man
Joe Alwyn in our first look at the
upcoming Netflix documentary Miss
Americana that feels awesome the trailer
for Taylor's new dock was released on
Wednesday and fans got a glimpse into
her personal life including her year
away from the spotlight after 1989 and
before reputation you know when all that
Kim and Kanye drama went down and that
was what I thought they wanted I had to
deconstruct an entire belief system toss
it out and rejected the 30 year old
singer got candid about just that and
her choice to speak out politically I
need to be on the right side of history
Taylor Swift too broke her silence on
politics in a whole new way she also
revealed why she didn't feel bold enough
to do so before throughout my whole
career label executives would just say a
nice girl doesn't force their opinions
on people
a nice girl smiles and waves insists
thank you I became the person everyone
wanted me to be in a recent interview
with variety the documentaries director
Elana Wilson said the film looks at the
flip side of being America's Sweetheart
it's um a lot of pressure to put on
yourself and although we don't see it in
the trailer
Taylor confirmed to variety that we'll
see both Kanye gates in the film and
then I was really excited because Kanye
West was on the stage and then I then I
wasn't so excited anymore me and Taylor
my still had wow I made that famous we
also got a behind-the-scenes look at the
making of Taylor's most recent album
lover and here's Taylor in the studio
with producer Jack Antonoff and a panic
at the Disco's singer brendon urie t
swizzles
cats will be making a cameo and you
guessed it will see some PDA between
Taylor and her beau of three years actor
Joe Allen but according to Variety
editor Chris Willman not too much I
think her fans already know so much
about her that they won't be surprised
how very candid she is she's not candid
about her love life that is barely
glasses upon at all so anyone looking
for that you know she still keeps that
under wraps it was happiness without
anyone else's input
[Music]
Taylor also shares a few sweet moments
with her mom Andrea no one out there
that I know of in the audience actively
hates me according to Taylor the doc
will include her mom's battle with
cancer that's been one of my ways of
coping with things Andrea was first
diagnosed with breast cancer in April
2015 and had been in remission but
Taylor confirmed to variety that it
returned while filming the documentary
and doctors discovered a brain tumor
Taylor said the entire process has been
really hard for her family quote
symptoms of what a person goes through
when they have a brain tumor is nothing
like what we've ever been through with
her cancer before I knew that things
were sort of emotional in their camp but
I didn't know why so I was a little bit
saddened and taken aback when that came
up in the interview almost certainly we
knew that you know she had reasons for
scaling back her taurine activity next
year and she confirmed that she was
scaling back recurring activity largely
because she wants to be available for
her family and her mother in particular
and get excited because Chris also
revealed we will be getting a new song
from the film that has a special meaning
the new songs in the documentary is
called only the young and something she
came up with during the lover sessions
within health back didn't think it was
right for that album and she wanted to
have it come out at a time when it might
influence young people to get active
politically because she wrote it after
her disappointment about the midterms
she got involved in and so you know it's
a very politically socially conscious
song it doesn't
espouse any causes but it's basically
telling young people who might be
disappointed by what's going on
politically that you need to take action